[Music]
I've had some experience in the great
country of Finland and they are
completely unselfconscious about their
bodies is it that way when you're living
in in in Sweden yeah I mean let's just
put it this way I've been naked in a
sauna with my grandfather and father and
cousins I mean that's just kind of how
it works which is not necessarily how
you want it to work but it just does
yeah that would never happen any it
wouldn't I mean I was young I don't
still do that to this day but you know
when you're a kid it's kind of like you
know your parents are kind of you you
see them nude you see nudity you see
nudity that is yeah until you're you
know past 10 it kind of that goes away
but it's very open and you see nudity on
television and it's not it's there's
nudity on television but I mean and not
just like you know we have nudity on
television but you got to pay for that
extra channel you gotta wait so the kids
are asleep and you gotta lock the door
you're talking about you're just
watching their version of Sesame Street
and a new guy no big bird or a
snuffleupagus you know
no it's not we're not that crazy right
that's right that would be crazy what
I'm describing I remember when I was in
Finland they were always saying you must
come to sauna and you'd go in and it was
just penises everywhere it was like
opening a shack filled with penises and
they're all like you take a sauna sauna
and you've gotta go in the sauna and
then they'd love to jump into the ocean
yes it's freezing freezing cold dead
Avenger and yeah it is shrink the people
do that like you go and you we have like
midsummer celebrations and stuff and you
go to people's country places with now
you're like in your early 20s maybe in
your late teens and you're in sauna is
naked with your buddies and you know and
yeah it's it's it's quite the tradition
yeah it's really i I'm going there very
soon yeah I'm going there and I'm
staying I get back there yeah yeah cuz I
need to get comfortable with my new [ __ ]
let's see I need other people that get
comfortable with my back
oh just never once happened you have
when you get this is gonna sound like a
weird question but when you get do you
get homesick or ever for the traditions
I'm Sweden I do I do you know and and
mainly it's the food because that's
always what feels like home you know the
smell food so I go to Ikea
[Applause]
there's Swedish meatballs they're pretty
good are they is now the Swedish
meatballs that you get at IKEA are they
the real deal I mean they're not the
real deal but they're probably not even
real meat but it's pretty close it's
pretty close I mean we usually fry ours
and in butter and since they're crispy
on the outside they boil these and then
you know so it's it's like a really
watered down version of the real Swedish
meatball you tweeted a picture recently
of an authentic Swedish meal and I don't
even know what's happening here
it it it looks kind of like an accident
of some time it looks like an industrial
accident what what's happening in this
photo I see two hot dogs
yeah that's safe to say you are dad's
mashed potatoes crisped onion ketchup
and mustard and it is and is it all in a
taco shell in a tortilla
yeah and you can actually buy this at
like 7-elevens or gas stations you can
buy that at 7-eleven yeah it's called to
umbrella to umbrella to umbrella
you just made it sound like this ruler I
want a cuckoo clock where the little
bird comes out and goes to mr. Ola every
hour on the hour I'll make that happen
so you can get that at 7-eleven at 7/11
it was manufactured in the late 50s
there was sponsors